this video is sponsored by Manta sleep
no matter who you are or where you're
from or what game franchises you're into
or not into there's one thing all of us
have in common we all got to sleep the
benefits are quite frankly out of this
world and if there's one thing a lot of
us sleepers struggle with especially
those of us who like to play games or
stare at screens a lot it's falling
asleep or staying asleep or waking up
feeling energized after sleeping but
thanks to the ridiculously soft and
comfortable Manta sleep masks the future
is looking pretty damn bright which is
ironic because the masks are blackout
masks which block out all light I can't
see anything now using a blackout mask
to help fall asleep is already a pretty
cool idea but man to sleep takes it one
step further by buffing their sleep
masks with special effects I have the
man cool mask because I run warm and the
c-shaped eye cups put no pressure on my
actual eye balls while applying a very
light pressure around them which feels
really really good it also keeps my face
cool and I've noticed that I wake up
with less sinus pressure after sleeping
with it which is something that I
struggle with a lot in my personal life
so if you're a person who sleeps and I
know you are check out mantis Sly by
following the link in the description
below and using the code Bandit games
for 10% off your order you'll thank me
later and now on to the
video that's this is not my this is not
my computer where is it we like lore
here at Bandit games and some of it can
get pretty weird which we also like take
the Legend of Zelda for instance did you
know that Zelda is the girl and Link is
the guy I know 99% of you did but you
just know there's someone watching this
right now that didn't know that and if
that's you no worries I'm not judging
you but let's talk about some of the
actual weird lore this fantastic
franchise has to offer at the end of the
original Legend of Zelda link saves
Princess Zelda who returns to her
kingdom to rule 6 years later link
embarks on another quest in Zelda 2 The
Adventure of link to save another ancier
Princess Zelda who has been slum
lumbering Sleeping Beauty style in an
eternal nap for who knows how long at
the end of this game that Zelda awakens
meaning at this point on the timeline
there are two princess zeldas alive at
the same time maybe they ruled together
or maybe they fought for the throne or
maybe the new old Zelda just lived her
new life as a commoner who knows
speaking of the timeline something that
lots of fans don't know or don't really
think about is that since the third
timeline Branch the Fallen timeline is
considered a canonical branch of the
timeline that also means that the events
that made it happen are to be considered
Canon as well which is to say that
according to the lore of the franchise
link Must canonically Die to Ganondorf
in aine of time for this entire timeline
to exist however since all three
timelines are equally Canon and the
other two are dependent on him not dying
this means that canonically the hero of
time both lived and died at the end of
ocarine of time mindblowing and if link
dies and spawns the Fallen timeline
sorry I mean when link dies and spawns
the Fallen timeline for for some reason
the Beloved Zora race which used to be
friendly to hens becomes evil and even
worse they become green for the entirety
of their fallen timeline appearances
while remaining friendly in the adult
and child maybe they just really miss
Link in the Fallen timeline and speaking
of the Zora in the adult timeline they
have evolved trading their former fishy
fins for wings and becoming the reto
tribe causing the Zora as they were to
go extinct however in the era of the
wild both of these races the evolved
reto and the devolved Zora are present
in Hyrule at the same time of course
there are theories to explain this weird
bit of lore and in tears of the Kingdom
we have proof that there are other Zora
tribes outside of Hyrule which may have
evolved differently than the other Zora
but it's still a bit weird nonetheless
the game links Awakening originally took
place after the twin games Oracle of
Seasons and ages but when the lyns
Awakening remake came out it was
switched to now take place before the
two games what's weird about this though
is that it's not just another Zelda
Adventure on the timeline that can
pretty much be stuck stuck anywhere
given that they all deal with the same
kind of concept it's legitimately the
continued adventure of the same link who
first appeared in A Link to the Past and
also appears in the Oracle games so
apparently the timeline of Link's
adventures in the world of Hyrule is
changeable but enough about the weird
timeline and the weird timeline
Shenanigans speaking of A Link to the
Past in kakaro Village inside one of the
houses of the informant women link can
find a cuu underneath one of the pots if
he sprinkles a little magic powder on it
it will transform into a human human
Kaku hybrid even clucking before
speaking incomplete sentences at least
the human caku appears more or less okay
just a bit uncomfortable in their new
human form but who isn't uncomfortable
in their human form am I right ghosts in
The Legend of Zelda are called Poes well
typically speaking anyway sometimes
though there are other kinds of ghosts
that look and act differently than their
po counterparts and one such recurring
ghost would be the hand in the toilet
which appears in Majora's Mask Oracle of
Ages and Skyward Sword apparently it was
based off of an old Japanese folklore
tale about like a ghost grabbing you
from the toilet or something like that
but it's still a weird lore Edition for
the world of Zelda and all it ever
wanted is just some paper so it can
finally wipe and move on from this world
speaking of Poe though in aine of time
link can catch po spirits and bottles
after defeating them in combat in order
to sell them to the poe collector
however if link decides to use the
bottle within which he has entrapped a
Poe before selling it he won't release
it back into the world like he does with
bugs or pour it out like he does with
water he will drink it
which may heal him or hurt him so yeah
in Hyrule vengeful spirits of the Dead
can be drunk like a milkshake there are
many links across the series and now
thanks to games like four Swords
Adventures and most recently tear of the
Kingdom we know that there are also many
ganondorfs this means that just like the
spirit of the hero keeps link coming
back age after age there must also be a
spirit that keeps Ganondorf coming back
a spirit of the villain or Spirit of the
anti-hero if you will which means
fortunately that we've probably not seen
the last of of the Beloved gudo Warchief
villain you know this one wasn't really
that weird I'm I'm not sure why I put
this on the list but speaking of the
gudo in the era of the wild they have
pointy ears which fits in with everybody
else in hyu but originally in Ocarina of
Time the guto's ears were all rounded
deep lore explains this change as due to
years and years of interbreeding with
hens and eventually picking up their
pointy ear jeans but either way it is a
strange piece of lore to have originally
created and then kind of retcon for the
era of the wild especially since the
newest iteration of Ganondorf didn't
really seem to get the memo speaking of
the ancient gudo the leader that opposed
Ganondorf in aine of time was called
naburu who fun fact is the individual
that Voris is named after oh uh who's
Von aborus you ask oh it's this colossal
mechanical animal called a Divine Beast
that was a huge deal in breath of the
wild but then vanished Into Thin Air
before tears of the Kingdom anyway when
the hero of time first meets her in the
spirit Temple as a child she needs him
to crawl through a little child- shaped
hole in the wall that she can't fit in
and retrieve a treasure for her she prom
promises to do something great for him
if he gets her treasure which sounds
well enough I mean doing something great
for somebody could mean many things but
once link talks to her as an adult after
having beaten the spirit Temple 7 years
later she says that if she had known he
would become such a handsome man she
would have kept the promise she made to
him when he was a kid which really only
means one thing since it's related to
link being handsome so yeah kid link was
promised a favor in order to to get him
to do what nuburu wanted yeah I'm I'm
just going to leave that one alone later
on link lives out the rest of his days
in his original kid form and goes on to
his next adventure in the land of
termina and within the land of termina
aliens come at night to abduct cows I'm
not kidding aliens from another planet
only refer to as them show up at night
and abduct cows and even little girls if
link is not able to fend them off wiping
her memories and leaving her catatonic a
shell of her former self beating her
head every now and then creepy it is no
secret that Link and Zelda are connected
throughout the series but this
connection is sometimes heavily implied
to be romantic in nature such as in
skyred sword or the era of the Wild
games and sometimes it's heavily implied
to be familial as in siblings such as in
A Link to the Past in Ocarina of Time
now neither of these connections have
ever been explicitly proven in the games
which means this is more theoretical but
for the vast majority of the fan base
either a familial or romantic
relationship between the two might as
well be a proven fact or both depending
on which game you're talking about as
long as we don't go full game of thrones
with this franchise though I'll be okay
and Lin and Zelda and Ganondorf aren't
the only people that keep respawning
over the years so does Beetle so does
impa so does dumpe so do Tetris Pirates
and so does tingle but not every citizen
of hyu reincarnates so this means that
there are probably other specific
reincarnating Spirits perhaps there's
also a spirit of the merchant for Beetle
and a spirit of the protector for impa
and maybe even a spirit of the man in
tights for tingle and speaking of the
man in Tights not only is it weird
enough that he's a 35-year-old fairy boy
and a poser fairy boy at that but in his
Wind Waker appearance there was a poor
seabound sailor named David Jr who was
unfortunate enough to be in a shipwreck
one stormy night he was fortunate enough
to not lose his life at sea but was
again unfortunate enough to be washed
ashore at tingle Island where he was
found by tingle and enslaved immediately
and when he woke up get this tingle had
already changed his clothes into to the
tights he's wearing now and he's
currently forced to work for tingle for
the rest of his days what's the line
tingle Tingle Kulu limpa also according
to the events of the Wind Waker long ago
the Triforce of Courage was broken into
multiple pieces and Scattered across the
Great Sea and everybody should know what
the Triforce is at this point so I
probably don't have to explain that to
you but this means that the omnipotent
all wish granting Triforce is a physical
Relic that can be physically broken
which doesn't really mean anything but
it's just kind of weird to think about
the famous Song of Storms from ocarine
of time was both taught to link and
created by Him see as an adult this
angry little man in the windmill Hut
teaches link the tune by playing it on
his phonogram claiming that a mean kid
played it in front of him 7 years ago
and made the windmill spin faster than
ever which is why he's so pissed after
this when link travels back in time by 7
years link plays the song of storms in
front of the man becoming the very same
mean kid that made the angry man so
angry and taught him the song We love a
good time looping Paradox there are no
female gorons think about it have you
ever seen one every Goron calls every
other gouon brother and a lot of them
even sport beards which is you know
testosterone some people claim to have
seen an interview with the ocarine of
time script supervisor toru osawa where
he apparently states that there are
female gorons but their physical
appearances are so similar to male
gorons that you can't really tell them
apart and they all refer to themselves
with the same pronouns which I guess
explains the brother bit if this is to
be believed then any one of the gorons
could actually be female including daroo
but I wasn't able to find a source for
this quote so I'm not sure if it's real
and according to some brand new tiers of
the Kingdom lore the Goron known as Trey
claims that gorons are actually born of
the land as in they just kind of pop out
of a rock eventually either way though
there are no apparent females in the
race which is weird because you know
females are pretty cool last but not
least in breath of the wild one of the
funniest things to do with the dreaded
yiga Clan blade Masters is haunt them
with bananas they are truly bananas
about bananas their leader is even
called The Top Banana of the yiga clan
but the yiga used to be shik and the
shika at least the ancient ones share
this same banana faction if you drop a
banana in front of Monk masz koshia
which is the only ancient shika you're
able to be around in gameplay he will uh
do this exactly like yiga blade Masters
are they an ancient race of monkey
people who knows I can't fault them
though though I also share their banana
faction that was the list how many did
you know comment below with the number
if you learned something new leave a
like and if you learned three or more
new things you should totally subscribe
if you learned nothing I'm impressed but
you should probably subscribe anyway
because clearly you like video game lore
and that's exactly what this channel is
all about and of course if there were
some weird lore discoveries I missed let
me know that as well in the comments
below thank you so much for watching and
let me know if you enjoyed this new
lighter style of lore video if you did
I'll probably make more huge thanks as
always to my Bandit crew of which I have
a new name to announce say hello to Chaz
Carlson who just joined up if you'd like
to help support the channel and keep it
alive feel free to follow the links
below that's all I've got for this one
so be sure to follow me on my socials
and I'll see you next time this is
Bandit signing out
[Music]
peace
the